Irrenvorname, Nachname Langsamusch, natürlich.
Ja, der Vorname ist Paula, P A U L A, Paula.
Und der Nachname, Westermann, W E S T E R M A N N.
Westermann.
Mit doppel N.
Ja, doppel N.
Vielen Dank für das Westermann. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 40 Jahre alt.
Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 12. November 1985.
1985, okay.
Wie viel wiegen Sie da Zeit?
Ich wiege 65 Kilo.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,68 m.
68, super.
Vielen Dank, Frau Westermann.
Was kann ich positionieren?
Was betrifft Sie heute so uns?
Ja, ich habe so ungefähr seit 5 Tagen Bauchschmerzen.
Und die werden jetzt aber schlimmer.
Im Anfang waren die Bauchschmerzen nur so um den Bauchnabel herum.
Etwas links davon.
Aber jetzt sind Sie mehr im linken Bauch.
Auf der linken Seite.
Und etwas mehr so im Unterbauch.
Und das ist inzwischen tut es mir da sehr weh.
Okay, habe ich richtig verstanden.
Seit 5 Tagen haben Sie Bauchschmerzen.
Und die Schmerzen schützeln in die linke Seite.
Ja, hauptsächlich in der linken Seite.
Okay, und Unterbau.
Okay, ein starker Schmerz auf einer Skala.
Von 1 bis 10, Frau Westermann.
1 ist leichter Schmerz.
10 ist stärker Schmerz.
Ja, ich würde sagen, in den ersten beiden Tagen war der Schmerz so bei 2 bis 3.
Aber jetzt ist er bei 6.
6, okay.
Okay, haben Sie schon Medikamente dagegen?
Nein, habe ich bisher noch nicht genommen.
Aber wie gesagt, ich komme jetzt heute, weil es wird schlimmer.
Und Sie müssen das jetzt untersuchen.
Genau, das ist eine gute Entscheidung für Ihre Gesundheit.
Wie sind Sie?
Wie sind Sie hier für Sie?
Und ich kümmere Sie um.
Ja.
Und können Sie beschreiben, wie die Schmerzen sind?
Sind Sie drückend, krampfartig?
Also Sie sind mehr drückend und andauernd.
Und selten, aber mal kommt so eine, wie eine Welle.
Das ist dann sich verstärkt.
Aber meistens ist es ein Dauerschmerz.
Okay.
Ja, sind diese Schmerzen plus die, oder langsam angefangen?
Langsam.
Okay.
Sind die Schmerzen in färter Zeit,
Schlimau das ist für Sie geworden?
Weil Sie haben schon erwähnt, ja, die Schmerzen sind für Sie.
Anfangs waren Sie eher wenig und jetzt sind Sie bei sechs.
Sie sind schlimmer geworden.
Ist Ihnen für diese Schmerzen ein Asthöser aufgefallen?
Nein, habe keine Erklärung dafür.
Okay.
Hatten Sie so etwas früher schon einmal?
Nein.
Das ist neue für Sie.
Okay.
Und waren Sie schon für diese Bescheiden beim Arzt oder bei der Erstein?
Nein, bis jetzt noch nicht.
Okay.
Sind die Schmerzen immer da oder machen Sie es mal?
Nein, Sie sind immer da.
Okay.
Haben Sie Öbelkeit, Erbrechen?
Also ich habe etwas Öbelkeit.
Ich habe etwas Öbel, so seit gestern, aber ich habe bisher nicht erbrochen.
Kein Erbrechen.
Kein Gestern haben Sie Öbelkeit.
Okay.
Okay, Frau Westemann.
Abkizem von Iran bescheiden.
Haben Sie Schüttelfrost?
Also Schüttelfrost habe ich nicht, aber Fieber habe ich.
Fieber habe ich gemessen.
Ich habe gestern Abend gemessen.
Da war es 38,5.
38,5.
Okay.
Aber Sie haben keine Schüttelfrost, keine Nachschweiß?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Normalerweise ist er gut, aber seit diesem Bauchschmerzen,
seitdem ich jetzt die Bauchschmerzen habe
und auch das Fieber, ist mein Appetit nicht gut.
Okay.
Haben Sie in nächster Zeit Ab- oder Suche genommen?
Nein, ich habe mein Gewicht gehalten.
Ja, ich habe es gehalten.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr Schlafen?
Wie schlafen Sie?
Normalerweise schlafe ich eigentlich ganz gut,
aber seitdem ich die Schmerzen habe,
ist es nicht so gut.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Durchlaufen oder Einschlafen?
Also die letzten Nächte konnte ich nicht gut einschlafen
und ich konnte auch nicht gut durchschlafen.
Ja, beides.
Beides haben Sie Probleme.
Okay.
Sind bei Ihnen einige Krankungen bekannt,
Frau Westermann?
Ich meine damit Zuckerkrankheit, Brutus.
Ach so.
Ich habe Asthma, seit meiner Kindheit habe ich Asthma.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie dagegen ein?
Ja, dann nehme ich Spreis ein, Asthma-Spray.
Okay.
Inversion und wie heißt das?
Also das eine Mittel heißt Viani.
Viani.
Viani, dann nehme ich zweimal am Tag.
Und wenn ich Sport mache,
ich mache manchmal gerne ein bisschen Sport,
dann nehme ich vorher Salbutamol-Spray.
Salbutamol.
Okay.
Hab ich richtig verstanden.
Sie nehmen zwei verschiedene Spray.
Ja, hauptsächlich Viani.
Und beim Sport nehmen Sie Salbutamol.
Ja, vor dem Sport direkt, wenn ich jogge oder so,
dann nehme ich ein oder zwei Sprühstöße Salbutamol.
Okay, ja.
Ich habe richtig verstanden.
Danke.
Und, hat es noch Operationen?
Ja.
Also ich habe noch andere chronische Erkrankungen.
Ja, ich habe noch eine vergrößerte Schilddrüse.
Und da muss ich auch ein Medikament nehmen.
Und seitdem ich das Medikament nehme,
ist die Schilddrüse auch schon kleiner geworden.
Okay, seit wann haben Sie diese Erkrankungen?
Ja, seit 20 Jahren.
Seit 20 Jahren.
Und wäschchen Medikamente nehmen Sie regelmäßig ein?
Ja, nehme ich ein.
Elteroxin.
In welcher Dosierung nehmen Sie?
Dahinter steht 75.
Da nehme ich eine morgens.
75.
Okay.
Ja, haben Sie sonst die Erkrankungen?
Nein, sonst nicht.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, als Kind am Blinddarm.
Da war ich elf Jahre alt.
Und im Alter von 13 Jahren, also zwei Jahre später,
hatte ich einen Sturz beim Eislaufen, Schlittschuhlaufen.
Und da habe ich mir den linken Oberarm gebrochen.
Und das musste auch operiert werden.
Operiert?
Mit Operation behandelt.
Ja.
Hab ich richtig verstanden?
Mit 30 Jahren alt?
13 Jahre alt.
Hatten Sie heißen Laufen fragt?
Ja, beim Eislaufen, auf dem Eis Schlittschuhlaufen.
Wenn ich gestürzt, und da habe ich dann den Oberarm.
Den linken Oberarm.
Okay.
Sind bei Ihnen bekannte, sind bei Ihnen allergie,
oder haben Sie die Bekannte?
Frau Westemann?
Nein, nur beim Asthma.
Da habe ich Hausstauballergie, Hausstaub.
Und ich bin empfindlich auf Gräser.
Wenn die Gräser blühen, im Frühjahr, im Mai, im Juni, die Gräser.
Gräserblüht.
Und manche Graspflanzen, dann wird mein Asthma schlimmer.
Okay.
Sonst habe ich keine Allergien.
Rauchen Sie Frau Westemann?
Nein, eigentlich rauche ich nicht.
Super, ich gratuliere Sie.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, ich trinke mal ein Glas Wein, so 2 Gläser Wein pro Woche.
Pro Woche.
Okay.
Sie haben schon erwähnt, da Sie Support machen?
Ja, ich versuche, so 2-3 Mal in der Woche zu joggen.
So zwischen einer halben Stunde und einer Stunde.
Eine halbe Stunde.
Okay.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, das bin ich.
Super.
Und ich habe noch eine Frage.
Aber nehmen Sie nicht persönlich, das ist eine Routine Frage, Frau Westemann.
Haben Sie jemals drückenkonsumiert?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Sind Ihre Altein lebendig und sind sie gesund?
Also die Mutter lebt noch, die ist 68 Jahre alt.
Sie hatte vor einem Jahr eine Gallenblasenentfernung.
Als Operation.
Sie hat auch Asthma.
Und sie hat hohen Blutdruck.
Und der ist im Alter von 69 Jahren verstorben.
Am Darmkrebs.
Ist mir leid, Frau Westemann.
Dann habe ich noch einen Bruder, der ist 42 Jahre alt.
Der hat ein Marbus Bechtereff.
Bechtereff.
Haben Sie sonstige Geschwister?
Nein.
Okay.
Bezu kunzi rega mesi iran frau ars oda ira fraarstin?
Ja.
Super.
Haben Sie rega mesi monat blutunk bekon?
Ja, meine Periode ist in den letzten Jahren eher unregelmäßig.
Also nicht stabil.
Ja.
Okay.
Sind Sie in der Menopause?
Nein. Die Fraunärztin sagt nein.
Aber meine Periode ist unregelmäßig.
Mal nach 4 Wochen, mal nach 5 Wochen.
Ja.
Okay.
Was machen Sie beruflich, Frau Westemann?
Ich bin Krankenschwester.
Okay.
Arbeiten Sie im Krankenhaus oder in der Klinik?
Ja, ich arbeite in der Klinik in einer Funktionsabteilung.
Endoskopie.
Okay. Endoskopie.
Super.
Wie ist Ihre Familienstadt?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Ja, eine Tochter habe ich, die ist 9 Jahre alt.
Okay.
Wo Sie zusammen sind?
Ja.
Ja, Frau Westemann, ich habe noch eine Frage über die aktuelle Bescheidung.
Haben Sie Hautfarbeveränderung bemerkt?
Nein.
Ich habe noch eine Frage über die vegetative Phänomeneise.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Stuhlgang oder beim Stuhlgang?
Also, Wasser lassen ist in Ordnung.
Beim Stuhlgang habe ich beobachtet, normalerweise habe ich jeden Tag Stuhlgang.
Aber in den letzten 3 Tagen hatte ich keinen Stuhlgang.
Haben Sie Winz abgelassen oder?
Wenig.
Und haben Sie Blähungen?
Blähungen.
Nein, Blähungen habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Ich habe auch aufgefallen, dass ich seit einer Woche einen verstärkten Ausfluss habe aus der Scheide.
Ersterke Ausfluss.
Was meine ich damit, Frau Westemann?
Ja, Sekret.
Sekret kommt aus der Scheide.
Das ist sonst eher selten oder gar nicht der Fall.
Aber seit einigen Tagen habe ich das beobachtet.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Vielleicht seit 5 Tagen.
Okay.
Damit sind vier Fragen durch.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen oder etwas ergänzen?
Nein, mich unbedingt.
Ich hoffe, dass Sie mir bald helfen können.
Dass Sie mir bald wissen, was die Ursache ist.
Momentan kann ich noch nicht Sie her sagen, was Sie haben.
So als würde ich Sie untersuchen.
Dann habe ich Ihnen Brut abgenommen.
Okay.
Ja, anschließend würde ich ein Röntgen und Endoskopie machen.
Genau.
Dann können wir die weiteren Schritte beschüpkeln.
Ja, das können wir so machen.
Dann haben Sie jetzt einige Minuten Zeit,
die Patientensprache zu übersetzen in Fachsprache oder Fachbegriffe.
Denken Sie an so Worte wie Übelkeit,
wie Blinddarm-Operation, Gallenblasen-Operation,
Darmkrebs.
Und die Kolleginnen und Kollegen, die zugehört und zugeschaut haben,
haben vielleicht noch Fragen.
Frau Westermann.
Ja.
Haben Sie im Urin und Stuhl Blut bemerkt?
Hab ich nicht bemerkt.
Beim Wasserlassen habe ich auch keine Beschwerden,
aber mir ist kein Blut aufgefallen.
Danke.
Ja, ich denke, die wesentlichen Fragen sind gestellt worden.
Darf ich auch?
Ja.
Wann war Ihre letzte Periode?
Die letzte Periode war so vor vier Wochen.
Ungefähr vier Wochen.
Aber ich habe ja schon gesagt,
das ist nicht immer sehr regelmäßig, sehr stabil bei mir.
Okay, danke schön.
Hallo, was benutzt ihr für Verhütung?
Verhütung benutzt wir Kondom.
Ja, das sind Sie wahrscheinlich schweig geschafft.
Das weiß ich, das weiß ich nicht.
Okay.
Ich hätte eine Frage.
Ja.
Ich meine, Ihre Auswurf Ungewöhnliches,
vielleicht ein Stink,
einen wie eine unangenehme Riechen,
hat sich schon bemerkt.
Er ist ein bisschen weislich, gelblich.
Er riecht etwas, aber er stinkt nicht.
Er riecht etwas.
Okay, danke.
Haben Sie aufstoßen oder brennen?
Können Sie das noch einmal wiederholen?
Aufstoßen oder brennen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Kein Sod brennen.
Nein.
Aufstoßen auch?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Können Sie mir beschreiben, wie der Ausfluss aussieht?
Ich meine, vaginale Ausfluss.
Ich sage so weislich, gelblich.
Okay, ich habe falsch verstanden.
Ich habe Ausfluss.
Kein Ausfluss, Ausfluss.
Ja, danke.
Ja, ja, ja.
Was sind die Red Flakes dieses Falles?
Ich würde sagen, klar, seit fünf Tagen Bauchschmerzen,
Anfangs um den Bauchnabel,
jetzt mehr im linken Unterbauch, linker Mittelbauch.
Die Schmerzen haben zugenommen in den fünf Tagen,
jetzt gerade sechs.
Es besteht Fieber.
Der letzte Stuhlgang war vor drei Tagen,
sonst war der Stuhlgang, ist der Stuhlgang immer regelmäßig täglich.
Keine Gewichtsabnahme.
Die Periode ist immer in letzter Zeit etwas unregelmäßig gewesen,
jetzt zuletzt vor vier Wochen.
Es besteht seit einigen Tagen ein Ausfluss aus der Scheide.
Ich sage ganz bewusst die deutsche Bezeichnung.
Ein Ausfluss aus der Scheide, so etwas gelblich, weislich,
mit leichtem Geruch.
Ja, das sind so die wesentlichen Dinge.
Die Patientin ist voroperiert am Bauch,
Zustand nach Blinddamenentfernung in der Kindheit.
Es besteht noch eine Zustand nach Oberarmfraktur,
auch in der Jugend oder Kindheit.
Patientin hat ein Astmarbrontiale
und hat eine vergrößerte Schilddrüse.
Der Vater ist an einem Darmkrebs verstorben.
Das wären so die wesentlichen Fakten, glaube ich,
die man anführen kann.
Ja, ich habe eine Frage auch.
Beklopfen Sie in Unterbauch ein Geweide oder Knoten?
Also ich habe mal am Unterbauch gedrückt mit den Händen.
Das war sehr schmerzhaft.
Das ist sehr schmerzhaft.
Aber ich kann nichts anders tasten.
Das kann ich nicht.
Das muss dann jemand anders machen, eine Ärztin oder ein Arzt.
Ich kann das selber nicht fühlen.
Aber es ist sehr schmerzhaft.
Gut, die Kollegin hat sich verabschiedet.
Wo ist sie?
Ja, da sind sie. Hallo.
Wollen Sie es versuchen?
Ich probiere.
Ja, bitte.
Guten Tag, ich treffe Sie.
Heute habe ich eine neue Patientin.
Ich möchte die Patientin vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja, habe ich.
Okay.
Es handelt sich um Paula Westemann.
Sie ist 40 Jahre alt, 65 kg, 1,68 m groß.
Sie ist heute bei uns mit Abdominalschmerzen.
Sie ist seit fünf Tagen voll.
Sie hat sich als Durkent und Dauerhafte beschrieben.
Sie hat einen langen Zanbegon.
Sie ist dort im Hintergrund auf der linken Seite.
Sie ist auf der Unterbau.
wurde am Anfang mit zwei bis drei und in Ferla auf der Seite sechs mit sechs von zehn auf der Skala bewertet.
Ja, okay.
Und als mögliche Auslösa gab sie nicht an.
Und die desweiteren Klagdisi über Neusea seit gestern und verstärke Sekretion seit fünf Tagen,
und verstarke Sekretion seit fünf Tagen.
Wo ist die Sekretion?
Aus von von Wagina?
Von der Wagina.
Also die Patientin, Frau Paula Westermann, ist eine 40-jährige Patientin.
65 kg schwer, 168 kg groß. Sie berichtet oder klagt seit fünf Tagen über zunehmende Abdominalschmerzen.
Anfangs eher in der Umbilikalregion und dann in den linken Unterbauchziehend, linken Mittelbauch und Unterbauchziehend.
Gut, der Schmerz wird als drückend und dauerhaft beschrieben.
Und welleförmige.
Ja, und teilweise etwas wellenförmig. Es besteht etwas nausea ohne Emesis.
Und die Patientin berichtet zusätzlich über einen vaginalen Fluor.
Fluor ist der Ausfluss.
Vaginaler Fluor.
Das Sekret wird als weiß-gelb, weislich gelblich beschrieben.
Ja, weiß, lieb uns gelblich.
Und mit einem, wir nennen das Geruch, ist fötor.
F-O-E-T-O-R.
Fötor.
Ja.
Es gibt auch einen Mundgeruch aus dem Mund.
Fötor, X-O-Re.
Und es gibt eben auch ein Fötor eines Sekretes oder eines Fluors.
Das kann man, es ist manchmal eben von einem Geruch begleitet, nicht immer.
Also wir haben ein Fluor vaginalis.
Fluor.
Was hat die Patientin noch? Hat die Patientin Fieber?
Genau. Die Begatative an Amnesie ist unanfällig.
Bis auf Fieber gestern 38,5 Grad Celsius.
Wissen Sie, wo die Patientin gemessen hat?
Ja, ich habe diese Frage ganz vergessen.
Okay, wichtig ist, möglichst immer fragen, wo haben Sie gemessen?
Weil heutzutage gibt es viele Methoden, Fieber zu messen.
Die Patientin hat den Mund gemessen.
Und es bestehen, sagen Sie ruhig, es bestehen febrile Temperaturen,
febrile Temperaturen von 38,5, oral gemessen.
Okay. Ja.
Oralgen.
Gibt es sonst Auffälligkeiten?
Genau. Die Begatative an Amnesie war unanfällig bis auf Fieber.
Und Obstipation seit 3 Tagen.
Und Inappetanz auch seit 5 Tagen.
Und Beschwerde bedingt in Sonny.
Okay. Wie ist die?
Gibt es Beschwerden bei der Mikzion?
Mikzion ist ganz normal.
Okay. Gut. Ja.
Genau.
Anfrag rankungen.
Habesie Asthma.
Habesie seit Kindheit, seit der Kindheit Asthma.
Sagen Sie ruhig Asthma-Bronchiale.
Asthma-Bronchiale.
Es gibt ja auch Asthma-Kardiale.
Aber sagen Sie Asthma-Bronchiale ist natürlich das häufigere,
aber ruhig Asthma-Bronchiale sagen.
Okay. Danke. Asthma-Bronchiale.
Und hepo seit 20 Jahren hepo tiroise mit Schutruma.
Ja. Oder man kann sagen, seit 20 Jahren hat die Patientin eine Stromer.
Mit wahrscheinlich, wir wissen nicht, ob sie eine hepo tiroise hatte,
aber sie hat zumindest eine Stromer.
Genau.
Und wie wird das behandelt?
Mit ectroxin.
Ja. Und welche Dosierung?
75 morgens.
Ja, 75 Mikrogramm morgens.
Mikrogramm morgens.
Und dieses Asthma ist das, weiß man, die Ursache für das Asthma?
Genau. Zihabe bekante allergigen Haustau und Graspflanzen.
Ja, Gräser.
Okay. Und wie wird das behandelt?
Mit Zarbuthamol und Viani.
Zwei verschiedene Cypher, Benutze, Zvianis, Zvaymaltekli, Zarbuthamol,
Fordem, Schuport, Zvaymalt.
Okay. Gut.
Gibt es Auffälligkeiten sonst in der Vorgeschichte bezüglich Operationen?
Genau. Im Artifon elf Jahre hatte sie eine Appendectomy.
Ja, eine Appendectomy.
Und im Artifon 13 Jahre hatte sie ein Laufunfraktur.
Was war eine Fraktur?
Ah, linken Oberarmfraktur.
Ja, aber Sie kennen den Begriff für Oberarm.
Oberarm. Oberarmfraktur und mit Operation behandelt.
Ja, aber wie heißt der Oberarmknochen?
Oberarmknochen.
Humerus.
Eine Humerusfraktur.
Am Alter von 13 Jahren hatte die Patientin eine Humerusfraktur links,
die auch mit Ostiosynthese versorgt wurde oder operiert wurde.
Gut. Können Sie mir etwas zur Familienvorgeschichte sagen?
Genau.
Ihre Mutter ist 18 Jahre alt.
Ja.
Aber vor einem Jahr wurde bei ihr kolesistisch durchgeführt.
Okay.
Was hat die Mutter noch?
Sie habe Asthma.
Asthma-Bronchale.
Und eine Arterelle Hypertonie.
Sie haben gesagt, die Mutter sei gesund.
Das wissen wir nicht genau, ob sie wirklich gesund ist.
Die Mutter ist 68 Jahre alt.
Sie hatte vor einem Jahr eine Cholizistik-Tomie.
Sie hat zusätzlich noch Asthma-Bronchale
und eine Arterelle Hypertonie.
Dann sagen Sie gar nicht, ob sie gesund ist oder nicht gesund ist.
Das würde ich gar nicht sagen.
Danke.
Gibt es Geschwister?
Ja, sie habe Bruder, genau, der 42 Jahre alt ist.
Und er hat Morbus Bechterov.
Morbus Bechterev.
Kennen Sie die Erkrankung?
Bechterev.
Ja, ich habe neue gehört.
Ja, es ist eine Versteifung der Wirbelsäule.
Die Patienten haben ein bestimmtes Band an der Wirbelsäule.
Ich glaube, das vordere Längsband ist Versteifend an der Wirbelsäule.
Die Patienten können sich ganz schlecht nach vorne bewegen.
Sie haben also eine ganz wenig Bewegungsradius.
Das wirkt sich bei manchen Patienten ungünstig auf die Atmung aus.
Ein Morbus Bechterev ist auch eine sehr starke Behinderung.
Man muss immer viel Physiotherapie machen, um das möglichst frühzeitig zu erkennen.
Aber man kann die Versteifung der Wirbelsäule eigentlich nicht verhindern.
Es ist eine etwas seltene Erkrankung.
Da unten steht auch Spondylitis ankylosans.
Ein Kollege hat geschrieben, das ist der Morbus Bechterev.
Am Ende mit weh geschrieben.
Spondylitis ankylosans.
Okay.
Eine etwas seltene Erkrankung.
Meine Frage ist, was ist Ihre Verdachtstiagnose?
Die Analystinangaben deuten amesien auf Pervic Implementar disease hin.
Können Sie das noch mal wiederholen?
Pervic Implementar disease.
Was ist dort alles im kleinen Becken oder im Becken der Frau?
Das sind die weiblichen Geschlechtsorgane.
Die Adnexe. Die linke Adnexe.
Es könnte eine Adnexitis sein.
Es könnte eine Erkrankung sein.
Die Frau hat Fieber.
Die Frau hat vaginalen Flur.
Es kann eventuell eine extrauterien Gravidität sein.
Wir wissen es nicht genau.
Es kann auch eine Erkrankung sein.
Denken Sie an Organ, was da direkt in der Nachbarschaft liegt.
Was für ein Organ kann das sein?
Es kann eine Diagnose sein.
Es kann eine Sigma-Diverticulitis sein.
Sigma-Diverticulitis.
Die Diaveticulitis ist am häufigsten im Sigma.
Das Sigma liegt ja nun auch anatomisch in direkter Nachbarschaft.
Von der linken Adnexe.
Eine Sigma-Diverticulitis ist oft in den Nachbarschaft.
Es ist oft in den Nachbarschaft.
Es ist oft in den Frühstadium lange Zeit stumm.
Es macht keine großen Beschwerden.
Aber irgendwann kommt es zu dieser Entzündung.
Es kommt zu dieser Entzündung.
Es erklärt auch das Fieber mitunter.
Es kommt auch zum Stuhlverhalt.
Obstipation ist manchmal etwas großzügig.
Ich würde sagen,
man muss aufpassen,
dass man einen Ilius entwickelt.
Die Frau.
Durch die Entzündung kann es natürlich sein.
Aber diese beiden Organe kommen in Betracht.
Die linken Adnexe.
Im Sinne einer Adnexitis.
Und auch das Sigma.
Es ist aber nicht wichtig,
dass sie die richtige Diagnose stellen.
Ich kenne die richtige Diagnose auch nicht.
Wir müssen noch andere Untersuchungen haben.
Wir müssen die körperliche Untersuchung haben.
Die ist wichtig.
Die ist eine gute körperliche Untersuchung.
Natürlich sollte dann auch eine gynecologische Untersuchung gemacht werden.
Es muss sicherlich das Labor
mit Entzündungsparametern gemacht werden.
Das ist ganz klar.
Und wahrscheinlich eine Bildgebung.
Ultraschall.
Oder eine Computertomographie.
Oder das in dem Krankenhaus zur Verfügung steht.
Das ist schon so.
Und wichtig ist,
als die Frau ist Krankenschwester vom Beruf,
sie weiß selber, dass sie nüchtern bleiben muss.
Und darf jetzt nichts mehr essen.
Sie muss in den Falleingriff kommen.
Wobei eine Sigma, die vertikuliert wird.
Es wird ja heute zum Beispiel versucht,
erst mal antibiotisch zu behandeln.
Und im Intervall eine OP zu machen.
Wenn es notwendig ist.
Auf alle Fälle.
Man kann ja auch sagen, es ist ein akutes Abdomen.
Vielen Dank.
Ich habe sie sehr gut verstanden.
Sie haben das sehr ruhig gemacht.
Im Anfang hatte ich gedacht, sie vergessen,
nach Stuhlgang und mitruf zu fragen.
Das ist ein Ende eingefallen.
Was natürlich bei solchen Beschwerden absolut wichtig ist.
Zu fragen, wann war ihr letzter Stuhlgang?
Wenn die Patientin dann noch sagt, vor 3 Tagen.
Und sonst ist er immer regelmäßig.
Das ist eine Veränderung, die ist schon wichtig.
Die muss man sich dann schon gut bewerten.
In der Einordnung der Symptome.
Wenn Sie jetzt mal den Oberarm nicht vergessen haben,
Humorus, Sie wissen die Begriffe, glaube ich.
Aber Sie müssen Ihnen jetzt in so einer Situation auch einfallen.
Das ist immer das Problem.
Aber ich finde, das haben Sie sehr gut gemacht.
Haben Sie schon einen Prüfungstermin?
Genau.
Am Ende des Jahres.
Vielleicht sehen wir uns dann nochmal.
Das ist bei mir.
Ich mache Sie in aller Ruhe weiter.
Achso, die Frage, wo machen Sie die Prüfung?
In Freiburg.
Da habe ich studiert.
Und auch lange gelebt in Freiburg.
13 Jahre.
Freiburg ist eine sehr schöne Stadt.
Wo sind Sie denn in Freiburg oder in der Gegend?
In der Nähe von Lörra.
In Weher.
Sehr schön.
Das ist ja auch nicht weit nach Basel.
Genau.
Ja, schön.
Da wohnen Sie in einer sehr schönen Gegend.
Dann würde ich sagen,
danke auch an die Gruppe für die Mitarbeit.
Danke für das Verständnis.
Das ist gestern nicht geklappt.
Aber nächsten Donnerstag.
Dann treffen wir uns nächste Woche.
Tschüss.